[muzyka]
[oklaski]
PP - It's Black Czarna obwódka to kule
inne sklepy
ciąg dalszy dnia, nie robię już pizzy ale
Nadal posiadam ten silnik
Naprawdę chcę cię zapytać
ludzie z Donbasu, no, jak wtedy, kiedy byliśmy na
wschodni, cóż, ominęliśmy ten cywilny
ominęliśmy obiekty Grażdanskiego
w każdym razie nie weszli do miasta Ne
ponieważ baliśmy się, ponieważ my
zrozumiał, że jest ogromny krzyk dużych
otarł się od strony cywila
populacja jest ojcem stworzeń, dla których jesteś
utopić diabły, [ __ ] ludzie giną w zwykłych
Cywile Cóż, to nie jest jak Brezgut We
чем Cóż, dla mnie ten typ jest bardzo niski
historia
po prostu
Przed ostatnimi wydarzeniami studiowałem na
Narodowy Instytut Obrony Ukrainy
poza tym mam własną działalność
Robię ubrania dla ludzi, kilka T-shirtów
tacy inni
Wiedziałem, że tak będzie.No to chodźmy
mówią to od 8 lat, ona nam nie wierzy
powiedzieli Nie, to wszystko fikcja, bla bla
przed wojną byłem przede wszystkim fotografem
Cóż, mam nadzieję, że to było przejściowe
historia
Rano Lenya w zasadzie zadzwoniła
zrozumieli, że tak się stanie, myśleli o sobie
żeby mnie to teraz nie spotkało
ogólnie wydaje się bardzo ważne uh
aby wskazać, że wojna nie zaczęła się 24-go
zaczęło się w lutym i trwa już osiem lat
Dziś Rosja rozpoczyna trzecią
wojna światowa jest wyzwaniem dla absolutnie
wszystko dla wszystkich struktur politycznych świata
dla wszystkich struktur wojskowych świata
Nie znam nowej rundy wyścigu zbrojeń
wszyscy próbujemy nas tu zatrzymać
zamówienie
każdy ma tutaj swój osobisty
broń i narzędzia
środków ochrony osobistej, tak aby
w razie potrzeby można to było zrobić szybko
weź się w garść i
ćwiczyć określone zadanie
Teraz dokładnie zapamiętam jednostkę
jest w pełni rozszyfrowany
grupa zadaniowa wsparcia patrolu
Policja
ta jednostka to taka historia, cholera, nie jest
pododdział Jesteśmy z Matiosem z Magyar
przybyliśmy tutaj jako miejsce zbiórki
potem ta kukułka zadzwoniła do mnie
szef policji patrolowej Kijowa i
poprosił mnie na komisariat
policjantów, którzy zaczęli wyjeżdżać do
wyzwania, ponieważ wtedy lądowanie
Goście mogą zejść na ląd
jest na szefa, tutaj mamy centrum dowodzenia
centrum planowania Lepiej tam nie strzelać
łóżeczko Przepraszam
i możemy przejść dalej korytarzem
teraz wszelkiego rodzaju rzeczy humanitarne są bardziej popularne
komunikacja między różnymi
jednostek między różnymi rodzajami wojsk
bo sytuacja jest teraz bardzo trudna
istnieje coś takiego jak
eskortowanie ważnego ładunku Cóż
na przykład jedzie tam samochód, który jedzie 600
kamery termowizyjne są potrzebne, ale są
komunikacja między obroną terytorialną
nie powołano policji patrolowej Sił Zbrojnych Ukrainy
Oznacza to, że przydzielamy nasz transport, który
ma komunikację ze wszystkim, co tworzymy
puzzle, robimy trasę i sprowadzimy ten samochód
tak, że te kamery termowizyjne na przykład
mógł wejść jak najszybciej
obserwujący Wczoraj nawet zadzwoniliśmy do siebie
pięknie wymyśliła Sofia Pipets
boomboxyuha wymyślił tak
[oklaski]
Lenya zadzwoniła do mnie i powiedziała, że ​​słucham
Nie mamy lekarza. Czy byłbyś gotowy?
nas dołączyć od hospitalists ja
powiedział, że jest Hal
mamy obowiązek zapewnić wszystkim
wymagane przez niniejszą podsekcję, tj
zaczynając od
jedzenie i kończąc na ciężkim
ciężka artyleria
naszą gościnną wiewiórką jest wiewiórka Elena
mój partner jest również szpitalnikiem z
w pierwszym dniu w szpitalu Współpracujemy z
ona jest sparowana z szpitalnikiem w pierwszej kolejności
zwykle działają w kierunku taktyki
medycyny i udzielania pomocy rannym w
bitwy, ale ponieważ więcej osób jest połączonych
z lekami w tym oddziale nie ma ot
wtedy cała gromada zatrzymała się u nas
domowe problemy medyczne, to [ __ ]
gorączkowa głowa
całe kule treningowej terakoty
ale używamy ich do treningu
personel
podstaw udzielania pierwszej pomocy a dokładniej
leczenie ran
Nie miałem wątpliwości, że stoję celowo
Pieprzyć skurwiela, bo to wiedziałem
ogólnie dziwię się, że jeszcze tam jesteś, cholera
Muszę fałszywe stanowisko może zrobić kilka
[ __ ], nie znam się na kłamstwach, jesteś obiektem
numer jeden, kochajmy cię ostrożnie
proszę przez ten bom
tutaj mamy żołnierzy, tutaj oni ich
ich miejsca do spania są prywatne
rzeczy przeszło część jednostki
szkolenie
od profesjonalnych instruktorów o godz
operatorzy
odpowiednio kiedy i czy
Przyjedzie do nas Tanchyki z Kacapa
mamy coś wspaniałego, aby je odrobić
facet z Troeszczyny i obywatel
Stanów Zjednoczonych
Ile masz rotacji w Afganistanie?
w Afganistanie była jedna rotacja
to znaczy osoba wzięła urlop z Akademii
Film Academy w Los Angeles przez pewien czas
pandemii, a potem, kiedy zaczęła się ta
Wicher zamiast zbierania ubrań
i chroń swój tyłek przed Nim
zdecydowałem się zostać z nami, wszedłem
czasopismo
wino i zawód - to jest praca.Tak, to jest to
nie możesz tak po prostu wziąć i tam pojechać
szukanie sabotażysty jest [ __ ] nie-nie
jest zrobione, nazywa się to przygodą, jeśli my
mówimy o operacji o bitwie, że jest to konieczne
trzeba to przygotować, trzeba to zaplanować
wybrać pewnych ludzi, którzy nim będą
wykonywać muszą znać swoje umiejętności
umiejętności ich mocne strony słabe strony To jest to
bardzo, bardzo trudna historia
Nie mam ochoty zabijać, ale to nie jest
anuluje fakt, że ich zadaniem jest ich dodanie
Mam karty do głosowania, tak, jestem gotowy
Naprawdę chciałbym poćwiczyć i poszaleć
Chciałbym wierzyć w to, co się dzieje
teraz jest
egzamin końcowy
dla Ukraińców W końcu doczekamy się swojego
niepodległości już pokonaliśmy Rosję
w pewnym momencie przez wiele lat straszyli cały świat
ich wojsko
zdolności militarne iw finale
w razie czego nasi pereosnicy trafili w chuja
Cadillaki, których boi się cała Moskwa
Cóż, to zabawne, po prostu je rozwiniemy
mogą to zrobić, rzucić nam
mięso kiedy
wystarczająco dużo ludzi na całym świecie
to zrozumie
Reżim Putina jest prawdziwy
zagrożenie jest realne bez przesady
zagrożenie dla całego świata niż my
wygrajmy może być nowy
etap ewolucji nas jako ludzi w nas jako
mamy obywateli jako społeczeństwo
naród i my Jak ja się stąd wydostanę i kiedy to gówno
skończymy usiądziemy
porozmawiać i zdecydować, jak będziemy tam kontynuować
żyjmy, pierwszym zadaniem jest walka
walczyć, wycofać kraj
Donbas czyni nas prawdziwymi
Niezależność To jest takie silne
silny tak, że Rosjanie w eh
wzmianki o Ukraińcach przyprawiłyby ich dzieci o dreszcze
rozpoczęliśmy to, nasze zadanie numer jeden
[muzyka]
autoafirmacji nawet jako silnego kraju
więc nie chwytaj tylko niszcz nasze
poradzi sobie z krajem
widzieć siebie tak silnymi, jakimi jesteśmy
możemy go tam po prostu zabrać i tam zniszczyć
kilka wiosek w kilka minut
[muzyka]
Cóż, jestem ochotnikiem na froncie?
właściciel używanych dronów pauzuje między
w 15 roku i
W 22. roku nie został wypełniony, jeśli
nasza ziemia jest pełna odpoczynku
bardzo piękne, a fotografowanie dronami jest świetne
pięknie możesz
[muzyka]
Istnieje takie hobby, jakim jest fotografia lotnicza
powiedzieć, że jestem tam również jego zwolennikiem
[muzyka]
okazało się, że my i usługi są niezwykłe
poszukiwany przez wojsko Cóż, na szczęście w
zasady Zdecydowaliśmy o wielu, wielu
zadania z pomocą tych dronów zrobimy
rozwiązywać
Mam jeszcze trochę wiedzy w tej dziedzinie
Mam tego trochę i tyle
w kompleksie bardzo mnie przywrócił
szybka inteligencja dosłownie w pierwszym
w czasie wojny poskładałem wszystko, co miałem
Przygotowywałem to, rozumiem, że wojna
może zacząć
teraz całe życie jako armia opiera się na
drony to po pierwsze oczy wojny, po drugie -
nadal jest elementem szoku
to przede wszystkim wykrywanie wroga
musisz zobaczyć, co się dzieje na tym
stronie, aby wiedzieć, które właściwie
działania, które powinniśmy podjąć, gdzie strzelać artylerią
jak umieścić swoje pozycje odwrotu
wycofać się i tak dalej
inteligencja zdecydowała realistycznie i
zadań humanitarnych polega na tym, że my
na przykład nie wiedzieli, co się dzieje
przez naszych uchodźców po tej stronie, tj
właściwie był jeden humanitarny
korytarz wzdłuż tego nasypu jest inny
korytarz humanitarny tam, na tym moście
na tym nabrzeżu
dowiedzieliśmy się, że jest tam problem
woda się podniosła i nie mogą tak po prostu
zrobili tam normalne przejście
zaimprowizowana tratwa, na której możesz
na przykład przejść przez jedną leżącą osobę
albo wszyscy inni muszą tak iść
woda, a następnie temperatura wody była
stopni jest gdzieś 3-4,5
co z tego, że nie każdy może to zrobić i właściwie tyle
z tego powodu był pewien, że tak powiem, pewny
taki problem z przyprawami, byśmy to zrobili
Oczywiście chodzi o mediację
Czerwony Krzyż został znaleziony tutaj bez klapy
taka mała łódka o wadze 70 kg i
po prostu rzucił, że jednak mogą
przejść na drugą stronę Cóż, jesteśmy jakoś tacy mali
ucywilizować przynajmniej ten proces
na tyle, na ile można go było uspołecznić
wszystkie sytuacje
mamy też inne informacje nt
coś zniszczonego w kim, to jest, dobrze
elementarni ludzie Może tam wiedzą
nawet chcę wiedzieć, w jakim stanie
ich dom
dla mnie wygrana oznaczałaby
demilitaryzacja Rosji
to znaczy, aby nie było prawdziwego wroga
będzie mógł ponownie nas zaatakować, aby do tego nie doszło
było realnym zagrożeniem
[muzyka]
to będzie zwycięstwo, to znaczy rozumiem jakie
teoretycznie możemy to osiągnąć
które nawet opuszczają kraj
ale rosyjski sen o tym, co nie pozostanie
nigdy nie zostaniemy zniszczeni, dlatego tak myślę
konieczne będzie osiągnięcie takiego parytetu
możliwości wojskowe Kiedy to będzie
z pewnością nierealne
[muzyka]
nasze straty sanitarne są znacznie mniejsze
przerodzić się w nieodwracalną stratę
czyli osoby, które zostaną ranne podczas
są znacznie mniej wojowniczy
umrzeć w wyniku tych obrażeń dzięki
praca na poziomie taktycznym, czyli walka
medycy, strzały, sanitariusze
ewakuacji, a nie na poziomie szpitala w naszym kraju
znacznie niższą śmiertelność w
ich z tych samych urazów, jeśli dobrze
anatomia to to samo co fizjologia
to samo w nich z tych samych obrażeń
umrzeć znacznie więcej
Właśnie przyjechałem i oto jesteśmy dosłownie dla
kilka minut przed przyjazdem
rozładowałem tak jak jechałem też teraz z
mnie za szkolenie lekarzy i wszystko tutaj
nieruchomość do szkolenia medyków mój lek
plecak
technika manekina, wszelkiego rodzaju rzeczy i takie tam
to jest nasze
główny węzeł komunikacyjny znajduje się tutaj
różne bandaże treningowe kołowroty B
Mam muzeum
teraz pokażę wam muzeum kapryśnych kołowrotów
Zabieram go ze sobą
skład niekompletny bo mam najbardziej kompletny
na Ukrainie kolekcja jest na ogół ich Ale
Pokazuję to, żeby wiedzieli, czego nie można zrobić
używać rakiet drukowanych w 3D
kołowrotki do drukarek firmy Ship iron
można go użyć bezpośrednio do zważenia grama 400 hrywien
To są rzeczy związane z [ __ ]
klej w sztyfcie z kilkoma haczykami do oczu
otwieracze są bardzo modne w Epicenter
są w sprzedaży i to jest nasz nowy ulubieniec
my on i ty jesteśmy helikopterem
jest gdzieś realny, no cóż, komuś nie dano takiego
wręczał prezenty z zagranicy
Nie wyobrażałem sobie sytuacji z
przez inwazję na pełną skalę Jednak I
Myślę, że bardzo się do tego przygotowałem
więcej niż niektórzy ludzie, którzy w niego wierzyli
Byłem w podróży służbowej do Stanów i tam byli
zastępca dyrektora ukraińskiego
funduszu kombatanckiego prowadził swój projekt
miasto reanimatroni, do którego szkolimy ludzi
pomoc lekarską i ustalić
defibrylatory w miejscach publicznych c
zabrało mi to chwilę
uświadomić sobie, co się stało, bo to ja bardzo
Widziałem to w 14 roku i
w pewnym momencie nawet poczułem, że ja
Jestem bardziej na swoim miejscu
twoje pudełko
niż wcześniej
to jest apteczka z mężczyzną ze szczątkami i
właściciele genetyczni, dlatego wchodzę
Rękawica jest zakrwawiona, tu się zdziwisz
jest bramka obrotowa, to chińska bramka obrotowa
narzucono nawet czas nagrywania
kiedy to był nałożony rosyjski
numer wojskowy jego drzew w naszym
potem położył chłopców na siebie, ale nie pomogło
A to jest apteczka Tank
i to jest właśnie klimat Drugiej
I wojna światowa, cóż
żelazo Ale nie musisz mocno uderzać
dać się oczarować My też takie mieliśmy
Apteczki były kiedyś jak apteczki samochodowe
ale tutaj jest cała w solarium, śmierdząc kapciami
prośby napływają każdego dnia zewsząd
Nie ma sposobu, aby nauczyć batalion uczyć kompanię
zajmuje dużo czasu i często
same dywizje nie mają tego czasu
dlatego jest dla nas bardzo ważne, aby wszyscy
Oddział miał swojego dobrego lekarza
ma i
w dobrym wyszkoleniu medycznym i can
szkolić swój personel wojskowy
zapewnić dokładnie taką wzajemną pomoc w
medycyna taktyczna jest właśnie tym
ustalić, czy są bardzo blisko lekarza
Piotra podczas Rewolucji Godności
protesty studenckie, a potem ja
tu również wstąpił do służby medycznej
byli wspaniali lekarze, ratownicy medyczni i pielęgniarki
wiele się od nich wtedy nauczyłem
Jasna dużo czytała itd. A my
ośrodki medyczne zostały otwarte, aby pomóc ludziom
Chodzi o to, że była bardzo, bardzo młoda i to wszystko
takie ale to było takie sytuacyjne
przywództwo Ktoś musi przejąć stery
odpowiedzialność
w 16 roku uczyłem się w międzynarodowej szkole
centrum utrzymania pokoju i bezpieczeństwa
Uczono tu poligonu Jaworów
Od tego czasu Amerykanie mają coś takiego
specjalność jako medyk bojowy
Po studiach pracowałem w Sztabie Generalnym i
stworzyliśmy program szkoleniowy
Wymieniono ukraińskich sanitariuszy
specjalność instruktor sanitarny przy ul
medyk bojowy i w momencie stawania się
dużo lepiej dłuższe przygotowanie
więcej obowiązków spoczywa na przyjmowaniu pacjentów
oraz medycyny taktycznej i instruktora
biznes, a teraz szkolenie kombatanta
medycyna na Ukrainie zajmuje tyle samo czasu
skoro w państwach w krajach NATO jest to 3,5
Niestety, oczywiście, nie mamy teraz miesięcy
możliwość szkolenia osób przez 3,5 miesiąca i
dlatego jest teraz bardzo zmniejszony
takie kursy są wstępem do specjalności
kursy dla
lekarzy cywilnych, którzy wstąpili do wojska
co powinno zmienić punkt ciężkości na cywilny
medycyna na klawiszach taktycznych pri-cztery
7-8 lat, podnieś ręce
bez względu na to, ile masz czasu na naukę
stale w ostrzale, jeśli nie strzelasz
pływasz, jeśli nie pływasz, biegniesz, jeśli nie pływasz
biegasz, uczysz się, jeśli nie uczysz się, śpisz
Wszystkie inne opcje nie mają rodzaju potrzeby
ciągle ciągle się ucząc w tym samym czasie
kontuzje Naszym zadaniem jest zapobieganie
strata krwi
Przygotujesz się dla mnie za dwa dni?
Nie przygotuję medyka bojowego
Solidar Strzelca przygotuję za kilka dni
czemu nie Albo jeśli tam jest fajny ratownik medyczny
z dużym doświadczeniem jest szybka potrzeba
kilka dni, aby dać mu trochę
zmień ustawienie ostrości, aby pokazać fragment, który
nie jest używany szybko, co my
wykorzystujemy to, co on ma i na odwrót
był na szybkiej ścieżce, której zdecydowanie nie miał
będzie z wojskiem i może
przemieniać
[oklaski]
jeśli wyjaśnisz, czym jest medycyna taktyczna
wyjaśnić termin Tak To jest przedmedyczne
pomoc w warunkach taktycznych tj
w warunkach działań wojennych obowiązują trzy główne zasady
medycyna taktyczna Ogień i odpowiedź
Właściwie bezpieczeństwo oznacza schronienie i tylko to
wtedy pomoc Piotra została uratowana
Ty
nie ma odpowiedzi, czy ci się uda, czy nie, ale
Zdecydowanie odpowiadam, co się stanie, jeśli
Jeśli pozostaniesz karmicielem, zostaniesz ostrzelany
gwarantowana śmierć, jeśli zostaniesz pod wodą
łuskanie sztuki, jeśli istnieje, jeśli się nauczysz
założyć opaskę uciskową od 20 sekund.No i co z tego
możesz sobie pozwolić na zrobienie
tamponowanie i cała reszta jest zrobiona
wyłącznie w chronionych po prostu dlatego
wymaga czasu cynizmu i czarnego humoru i
wręcz przeciwnie, są łzy i to nadmierne
emocjonalność to wszystkie ochronne reakcje na nią
z którymi nikt z nas nie chce się zmierzyć
przez śmierć ktoś wybiera swoje
zawodu, a potem jakoś się z nim uczy
sobie z tym poradzić
twoja postać nie przygotuje cię na to
być lekarzem, ale mieć dobre wykształcenie
Przygotuję pram-param-param-param
miejmy jeszcze jeden raz i jeszcze jeden teraz
wszystko taktycznie wymyślisz sam
reszta, no, bardzo
wymyśl dergs nooper, czego chcesz znowu
Chcę rozpalić kolejny ogień, bardzo to lubię
aby zobaczyć wyniki pracy i zrozumieć, co
wszystkich ideałów humanistycznych iw ogóle
Chciałbym tego i wszyscy moi koledzy
chcieli, żebyśmy nie mieli pracy oprócz nich
Naprawdę lubię to uczucie, kiedy to robisz
praca i wszystko się potoczyło, wszyscy są przystojni i
wszystko dobrze zrobione, dlaczego lubię uczyć, ponieważ
że to też ja bezpośrednio liczę ludzi
co może być bardziej prawdopodobne
przetrwanie po nauczeniu mnie i mnie
często piszą Tam dzwonią dzwonią
dzięki ludzie
którzy sami sobie nie dali pomocy, bo ja im
nauczyła mnie czegoś tam i to jestem ja To jestem ja
cieszy nawet bardziej niż moi pacjenci, którzy
Dziękuję, bo jesteśmy pacjentami
Dlatego tak o sobie myślę.No cóż, jest jeszcze jeden
dobrze, że mówisz dziękuję, ale ja
teraz myślę, że mogłabym tam zostać jeszcze dłużej
lepiej to zrobić lub jest ciepło
za co mi dziękujesz?
to było normalne, jak myślisz, kim jestem?
to była dama wskrzeszona z martwych, to były bzdury
w rzeczywistości, kiedy ktoś mówi cholera
Zrobiłem, co mówiłeś, i tyle
tipa z z bardzo mocno ładuje go bezpośrednio
ogień
[muzyka]
że dla mnie Ukraina jest tym, za czym się opowiadamy
żyjemy i umieramy konkretnie, ja konkretnie
moich przyjaciół, a konkretnie naszych
Nasze siły obronne i tak dalej ludzie często
myślą, za co warto umrzeć, tak myślę
trzeba pomyśleć o jednym, że warto
żyć i walczyć każdego dnia
nie chodzi tylko o to, żeby umrzeć
Okazuje się, że na Ukrainie zaczęło się 24 lutego
wcześniej nie było wojny w nocy
trzeba z nią walczyć, żyć nią nieustannie
walczyć na wszystkich poziomach, aby to zrobić
najlepszy
[muzyka]
jesteśmy w siedzibie wolontariuszy Tse
cafe doubler w czasie pokoju Obecnie to
duża siedziba wolontariuszy i centrum Kijów
wolontariacka organizacja charytatywna i
W związku z tym wszyscy tu jesteśmy
Cóż, zaczęliśmy od tego, że byliśmy tam wszyscy
pierwsze 3-4 odpowiadały tam odpowiednio
dni i zarządzanie Sashko Borovsky
instytucji, kaskader i dyletant pisali do mnie
zapytał, czy mam moskiewkę. Nie mam
zeszyty, nie ma to jak I jesteś w Kijowie, a ja w
Kijów i Saszka mówi I jesteśmy tam ze Sławą
wpadł na pomysł, że jutro chcemy otworzyć kopię zapasową
bo jest co gotować
wszystko jest zamknięte, wielu potrzebujących może
jeśli chcesz dołączyć, weź to
mnie, bo nie mogę już siedzieć i panikować
i nie jest dobrze się bać, powiedział Saszko
chodź I tam zaczęliśmy pierwszego dnia
kucharz 28 lutego otworzył kopię zapasową
dość szybko zebrał zespół ochotników
pozostali kucharze
wszyscy projekcyjni menedżerowie kelnerów
przebywał w Kijowie, wszyscy pochodzili
z wielką radością
wpadliśmy na pomysł już pierwszego dnia
przygotowano około tysiąca porcji
[muzyka]
stowarzyszenie zrzesza obecnie 25 restauracji
również trzy piekarnie, które obsługują
pierwszego dnia przygotowujemy codziennie na 10 tys
w marcu było ponad 10-12 osób
Kijów był tam zablokowany, więc byli karmieni
około 15 tysięcy osób we wszystkich kuchniach w
Pracuje dla nas 345 wolontariuszy, to także ludzie
kuchnia i ludzie tam pracujący
pakowanie, prace magazynowe
[muzyka]
24-go byliśmy tu rano w pracy
przyjechaliśmy o 5 rano i kiedy zaczęliśmy
wybuchy, czyli w których byliśmy
wszyscy zostaliśmy zwolnieni z pracy, łącznie z dwoma pierwszymi
dni nie wiedzieliśmy, co robić, to znaczy było
taka mała panika i 26
zadzwonił do mnie
facet tutaj z pracy powiedział dobrze
chodźmy zrobić z nami bochenki i
taki więc ja z tobą otrzymał
specjalna przepustka i poszliśmy we trójkę
pracować w tej firmie
Miecznikow To znaczy, zaczęliśmy tam
ponieważ było
trochę ciszej bo jest piwnica
Nadal byłem szefem kuchni w restauracji, a teraz jesteśmy
jesteśmy tutaj w naszej restauracji
przed wojną pracował jako więzień
restauracja A zamieniła się teraz w
kuchnia wolontariuszy, w której gotujemy
żywność dla potrzebujących dla szpitali
Ludność wojskowa Terrodefense
[muzyka]
Byłem w domu i zobaczyłem to w mediach społecznościowych
1. Cóż, pierwszy post, w którym zobaczyłem, co
ktoś potrzebuje
gotowe jedzenie i zdałem sobie sprawę, że mogę to zrobić
konieczność zamknięcia po wejściu do kuchni
restauracja i zebrałem zespół i to wszystko
zaczęła się praca z wolontariuszami i tyle
Kijowski wolontariusz zaczął na stałe
pomóc, czyli mieli taką potrzebę
dali mi jedzenie na gotowe obiady
i opakowania A ja jem gotowe dania
pieczemy około 500 sztuk dziennie
jednostek i przenosi się gdzieś w czasie
prawdopodobnie cały dzień, gdzieś około 10 godzin
tak bardzo zjednoczeni ze sobą
zaczął pomagać. To znaczy, że masz trochę
potrzeba czegoś, nie masz na to czasu
głos Jak ci się podoba każdy ze wszystkich stron
pomóż, to jest bardzo motywujące. To ty
jak się masz w bardzo dużych dużych
rodzina
Dziękujemy naszym właścicielom za pozwolenie
tutaj, aby zrobić to na ten numer, o który prosiłem
Mogę iść do kuchni przed spotkaniem
restauracji i pozwolono mi to zrobić
i od tego czasu trwa po raz pierwszy
Mam skojarzenie z chlebem, że to życzliwość
Wtedy ludzie kupują świeży chleb
natychmiast je słyszą i czują
uśmiechają się, czyli oto chleb dla mnie -
to jest tak. To uśmiech, jeśli potrafisz
mowić
Cóż, cieszę się, kiedy widzę to jedzenie
uszczęśliwia kogoś, tj. kiedy ktoś
nawet ci się spodoba
bo w tym i tak się w sobie czuję
każdego wieczoru pojawia się poczucie szczęścia
przez
porcje kilogramów setek kilogramów jedzenia
które gotujemy i które karmimy
ludzie tutaj
to dreszczyk emocji
[muzyka]
moi przyjaciele zadzwonili do mnie i powiedzieli, że to konieczne
trzeba gdzieś iść i zjeść obiad
samochód Możesz pomóc, ja mogę
przyszedł i tak po prostu wylądowałem tutaj i
każdego dnia po prostu gotują A ja
Bawię się codziennie
[muzyka]
Mam dwoje dzieci w wieku 16-18 lat i my
zdecydowaliśmy, że zostaniemy w Kijowie i
robimy co w naszej mocy, żeby coś tu było
pomoc Właśnie tutaj Ponieważ zrozumieliśmy
że ręce są nadal potrzebne w ten sposób
zaczęto szukać miejsca, w którym można by pomóc
raz zadzwonili do mnie i powiedzieli, że w
masz samochód, masz prawo jazdy, możesz
jedź po mieście Nie bój się Możesz
pomogę w dostarczeniu, więc będzie możliwość odbioru
z jednego punktu i prowadzić do drugiego i to wszystko
Zacząłem jeździć
Mamy również około 120 kierowców
wolontariusze samochodowi, którzy prowadzą samochody lub
gotowe jedzenie jest tam dostarczane w kombi
bezpośrednio do klientów i jest też kierowca
przewozimy ze sobą 12 z nich
surowców między instytucjami, a także
Jedziemy w region, niesiemy pomoc humanitarną
pomoc tam w obwodzie kijowskim we wsiach
na tereny okupowane w Czernihowiesku
region A teraz planujemy wyjazd
do Charkowa
[muzyka]
możesz kontynuować warunkową jazdę
Bucha Borodyanku są tam oczywistymi miastami
wiedzą o tych, którzy wiele wycierpieli, ale
taka jest właśnie moja strategia
naprawdę warto czasami sprawdzić stan tych miast
ale nie trać czasu i zrób rekonesans
Niektóre
odległe wioski
gdzie myślę, że potrzebuję pomocy
aby spróbować więcej w tej chwili mamy to tam
oddzielny zespół kierowany przez Zhenya Gorban i
Wolontariusze są w stałym kontakcie z władzami miejskimi
rady osiedli są w stałym kontakcie
wolontariusze Tam zbieramy prośby
oficjalne nieoficjalne Wyjeżdżamy teraz
z Kijowa naszym pierwszym celem jest
wieś ta jest osadą rejonu iwankowskiego Tse
bardzo mała wioska licząca około 10 osób
domów, ale w większości tam mieszkają
starzy ludzie i nie mają prądu
dlatego są w wielkiej potrzebie
Niektóre
podstawowy
idą produkty higieniczne i leki
tam teraz zdarza się, że po prostu
przychodzisz do wioski i rozumiesz, czym ona jest
jest odłączony, nie ma gazu, nie ma wody
nie ma elementarnych rzeczy, zatrzymujemy się
i odpowiednio tam pomagamy i przyjmujemy
opiekę nad tą czy inną wioską
[muzyka]
zniszczenie jest absolutnie barbarzyńskie
prawie nie wywołuje we mnie emocji, czyli mnie
Po prostu widzę to jako fakt, ale ludzie są bardzo
motywować i zachęcać, ponieważ ludzie
jakoś wciąż są pewni, że tam są
powinni być
wierzą w najlepszą przyszłość
na jakiś taki odpowiedni nastrój i nie
rzadko kiedy opowiadają swoją historię
historia Co się działo w czasie okupacji
Byłem bardzo zaskoczony
kiedy dotarliśmy do wsi Osowiec
po raz pierwszy jest to prawdziwa wieś, w której prawie
nie ma nic, tylko około 10 domów i
dookoła jest tylko las, tu nic więcej
i że nawet rakieta tam poleciała
dla mnie jest absolutnie niejasne, co jest czym
coś takiego może istnieć, gdyby było to konieczne
zniszczyć tę babcię
mieszkająca tam babcia przeżyła, ale ona
dostała dużego oparzenia na ręce i wszyscy zmarli
kury, które uratowały całą wioskę, bo one
złożył jaja, więc zdecydowaliśmy, że możemy
zbierać pieniądze i pieniądze i przywrócić ten
dlatego wszystko przygotowaliśmy w kurniku
jesteśmy mistrzami
z nich materiały budowlane
ludzi, którzy chcą dać pieniądze tylko na to
dziś pozostaje tylko zapytać v
jemu to nie przeszkadza
zmuszanie do czynienia dobra nie jest zbyt dobre
[muzyka]
drzwi zostały wyważone
u sąsiadów
drzwi biegły
zaktualizowane
nasz bohater
pojechał w cysternach
nasi są daleko od was jak proporce
chłopaki, nie dajesz Cóż, och, och, och, och, och, och
biały był bardzo głośny Tak, wszystko jest w porządku
Byli chłopcy
będą kapitalnymi facetami
Zdecydowanie uderzają. Zdecydowanie nie ma ich w wiosce
nigdzie nie trafić
dobrze zrobiony
profesjonaliści Dzięki Bogu
trzymać się
bardzo fajnie, że tak się trzymasz
taki humor
k Ale jest już 70 trzecia godzina
[muzyka]
Dzień dobry Anastasiu
aż do wieczora
taki przystojniak został pochowany młodo
młody
powiedz mi, czy będzie bolało, czy paliło
Proszę, przyjdziemy z Medykiem
Tobie na pewno coś doradzi
to dobrze Julia była bliżej nas
to wojna sprawiła, że ​​tak się stało
więc kim jesteśmy od ciebie?
zaakceptowane, że pozwalasz nam budować
stodoła Ale pójdziemy krok po kroku
wiśnia
się pojawi, przywieziemy je
Bardzo miło było z tobą porozmawiać
Dziękuję, trzymaj tak dalej, nie smuć się
żyć tak piękną wiosną, taką naturą
jesteś super, ogólnie taki człowiek
spoko tak trzymaj
przyjedziemy cię odwiedzić
[muzyka]
tyle osób wie dokładnie
o nas, bo po prostu robimy swoje
interesy, nie oczekując niczego szczerego
chęć pomocy, a wtedy to zrobimy
myśl, że na pewno tego potrzebujesz
powiedzieć, bo mamy ku temu powody
dla tego
Po miesiącu pracy zdaliśmy sobie z tego sprawę
to jest szczególnie cenne, że mamy takich ludzi
Wolontariusze są dla mnie najbardziej inspirujący
osoba, która przychodzi bez zmęczenia
dwóch miesięcy i 345 takich osób na wieś
restauracje 120 kierowców i więcej
bakotiaz i żaden z nich nie żałuje Nie
Nie, nie prowadzimy żadnych rozmów na ten temat
problemy z motywacją lub o problemach z
ponieważ o mój Boże, dlaczego robię to przez ciebie
wsiadasz do samochodu, przynosisz jedzenie, widzisz kim jesteś
dajesz, zobacz dla kogo to robisz I
każdego dnia otrzymujesz wynik
zadowolenie ze swojej pracy
wiele osób ma
będą problemy, będą problemy
niektóre podstawowe wiele miast zniszczonych temu
po zwycięstwie wszystko nie wróci
Będę do 24 lutego, a to oznacza, że ​​za
Mamy dużo pracy, tak myślę
wszyscy ludzie, którzy są teraz
zawarte właśnie w pracy pt
z czyjąś pomocą jakoś się zmieniły
przekształcili się
wydaje mi się, że po prostu nie mogę
wyłączyć i wrócić do kogoś
możesz po prostu odejść od swojego życia
do otwierania placówek i nic więcej dla mnie
wydaje się, że wolontariat dobrze się sprawdza
przynajmniej przez długi czas
jest zarówno darem, jak i twoim ciężarem, ale ja należę do niego
Bardzo się cieszę, że jest ze mną na zawsze
[muzyka]
Otóż ​​jestem Maria z Mariupola, mam 30 lat
jesteśmy w pobliżu budynku teatru
Lalki to pierwsze miejsce, w którym się znaleźliśmy
Lwów, kiedy przybyli tu z okupowanego
terytorium
Jest Nawiasem mówiąc, kiedy właśnie przejeżdżałem przez pierwszą na
że zwróciłem uwagę na to szkło
dach
ponieważ byłem w teatrze dramatycznym
kiedy upadł, a teraz my też jesteśmy w teatrze
i jestem taki szczęśliwy, idę, a potem patrzę
na tym dachu
zaczynasz zwracać uwagę na pewne rzeczy, które
potencjalnie może być dla Ciebie
niebezpieczne lustra są duże
okna coś innego
[muzyka]
do 10 marca. Wychodziliśmy codziennie
ulicę i poszedłem tam, próbując kupić
stać w kolejce po jedzenie i byli ludzie, którzy
w ogóle nie wychodził z domu
mieszkanie lub z piwnicy i dużo
ludzie i po prostu Cóż, spacerujesz po mieście i
rozumiesz, że wielu ludzi jest prostych
szaleją w nich histeria Ot
na przykład ty i każda inna kobieta
ona płacze i tak a tak.To znaczy, słyszysz
Tam strzelają, tam strzelają
strzelać Ale wiesz, czego potrzebujesz
woda
i idziesz ulicą w ten sposób, a my tacy jesteśmy
Chodźmy tam z mamą i coś przedyskutujmy
ludzie po prostu histeryzują tam, rozumiesz
ludzie nie rozróżniali dźwięków, kiedy to było nasze
artyleria strzela prochem i tacy jesteśmy
Oznacza to, że gdzieś leci
miasto, ale artyleria to coś takiego
bardzo Bacha i kiedy zdecydujesz się do nas podejść
strzelają na przykład, kiedy nasz nadchodzi
artyleria jesteśmy tacy Cóż, rozumiemy nas
siły bezpieczeństwa chronią nas teraz i są to ludzie
nie rozróżniali dźwięków, których nie rozróżniali
nie rozumieli, z której części miasta skąd
jest ostrzał, a oni są u jej boku
Tego się bali, to znaczy, że byliśmy sami
kiedyś staliśmy w kolejce po wodę i
nasza artyleria zaczęła strzelać i pół
kolejki właśnie uderzyły w ziemię Cóż, my
stoimy tak i mówimy, że to nasza studnia, jakby
co ty jesteś głupi czy co To jest to jest to
normalna artyleria jest krótsza na świecie
taka artyleria, że ​​nie można się jej bać
Ukrainiec Cóż, jeśli nie jesteś, oczywiście
usunąć rosyjskich żołnierzy
faktycznie siedzimy do 14 marca
tam na korytarzu bez jedzenia i wody i to my wszyscy
tacy byli
przebijmy się tam, nie ma rasy Kozaków
tłumaczenie żaden typ nasz nie daje przyzwoitego
ten rosyjski wcześnie Krótko mówiąc, tutaj jesteśmy tylko
prawdopodobnie po teatrze dramatycznym
spadło nam na głowy i zrozumieliśmy co
nie walczą z armią ukraińską
nie przybyli, aby zdobyć miasto
przyszedł, aby go zniszczyć i zabić wszystkich
[muzyka]
nie jesteśmy tego rodzaju fabryką
azastal A jak to samoloty latają i on
tuftuh
[muzyka]
a miejscowi bombardują tamtejszą fabrykę w ten sposób
Jak ukraińska armia
Niedługo wracam, wyjeżdżam
więc kiedy idę do teatru, słyszę lecący samolot
oparł się o jakiś budynek
teraz bombardujesz, gdzieś tam to bombardowało
To wszystko. Poleciał i mam to na myśli
Podchodzę do teatru i widzę, kim jest
zniszczone, nie mogłem nawet na początku
ułóż tę układankę, bo widzę kawałek
na dachu widzę ludzi chodzących po placu
po rozsypce widzę, że teatr taki jest
część już się pali, a ja naprawdę
Stoję tak, byłem tam na dole
częścią teatru Może już taki był
zniszczone jak ja, ale jak ludzie
krzyczeć
ranny I rozumiem, że jest tam moja rodzina
Zaczynam biec jak szalony tam i
Wbiegam do drugiej części teatru
Tam je przeżyłem, tam jest coś krótszego
Biegnę, dzwonię do nich, a potem ktoś do mnie zadzwoni
odpowiedzi Okazuje się, że były
w tych częściach teatru, które się nie zawaliły
zostały częściowo dotknięte, ale
nie zeszli do schronów
a ze schronu były wyjścia na ulicę
i stali w tych wyjściach i ja
zadzwonili, bo się o mnie martwili
był w parku
I że cierpiałam, bo dużo
osób, które nie znajdowały się wewnątrz budynku
ucierpiała fala uderzeniowa Ale my wszyscy
ugh
były cele, są rzeczy ważniejsze
niż jest histeria i zmartwienia i
na przykład To znaczy my na przykład 7 idziemy
pieszo i idziesz autostradą i widzisz to
mój Tutaj widzisz ceny i ludzie są tacy sami
I jest coś takiego i takiego. Cóż, masz jedno i drugie
idź lub zostań tutaj, wszystko jest przerażające
Nie martw się, wszystko jest teraz dla Ciebie ważne
idź Ale ostrożnie bez paniki
Lepiej być przygotowanym na coś złego
niż wierzyć w to, co cię spotka
jakiś cud Ale myślę, że co jest ze mną nie tak
stał się cud bo nawet zjadłam
czekolada, którą znasz z przewidywaniem i
zapisana tutaj jest przepowiednia zapisana tutaj
jest ktoś, kto jest młody, niebo jest tylko o tobie i
patrząc na moją historię myślę
że jest to bardzo trafna prognoza, ponieważ
zdecydowanie opuściłem Mariupol bez żadnego
zadrapania
Cóż, przede wszystkim zrozumiałem, że rzeczy materialne
wartości to bzdury, dla których tak naprawdę jest
potrzebujesz minimum szczęścia
rzeczy i najważniejsze jest to, że Twoi bliscy
byli z tobą. Zrozumiałeś, że byli w środku
bezpieczeństwa, żeby w ogóle była na Placu Czerwonym
był nie tylko Lenin
[muzyka]
też bardzo
bardzo dziś
prezydent
[muzyka]
nie można być gotowym na wojnę, wiedziałem
że ona będzie
ale wciąż nie jesteście gotowi do wojny
24 lutego był straszny chyba tylko w
wszystkich Ukraińców zasnąłem i zacząłem
Wydaje się, że jest 5 rano czasu polskiego
czwarty dzwoni w środku nocy
telefon i spałem odkąd byłem mały i teraz myślę
dziecko jest wychowywane, a tu matka woła i
Myślę, że rozumiem, że mamie na pewno by się spodobało
Nie pomyliłem tego i to jest czas, kiedy moja mama jest w środku
taki czas nie wzywa, nigdy go nie biorę
mówi do mnie cześć przez telefon promocyjny
zaczęła się wojna ja mówię gdzie ona mówi jak gdzie
na Ukrainie
Hepaye strzela do klawiszy Internetu iw
mieliśmy zaplanowaną rocznicową promocję
nawiasem mówiąc, okupacja Krymu jest dokładnie taka sama
dawać
i pod ambasadą Rosji wzywam
Od rana informuję policję, że trwa akcja
będzie, ale temat jest zupełnie inny i zwołujemy
wszyscy protestujemy za pośrednictwem Facebooka
faktycznie przeciwko wojnie
a wszystko i jak zaczęła się pierwsza akcja dalej V
Po tym byłem cały we mgle
dziesiątki promocji każdego dnia
Od tego czasu Warszawa jest w ruchu
akcje ambasady rosyjskiej przeciw
zakończenie wojny przed akcją w centrum miasta
Warszawy w solidarności z Ukrainą
[muzyka]
zbiórka pomocy humanitarnej dla wszystkich
tych akcji, ponieważ mamy rację co do akcji
przywieźli autobusy i poprosili o to ludzi
przywieźli leki przez Internet
wysuszyłem listę tego, co dokładnie trzeba kupić
ludzie biegali po całej Warszawie kupując
wszystkie apteki przywiozły nas samochodem i
kierowcy opuszczali samochody prosto z akcji i
udał się na Ukrainę
Ukraina
przede wszystkim zrozumiałem, co jest najważniejsze
zaangażuj się w pracę, nie zaczynaj się smucić
umrzeć końcem świata i ustawić się
strategia, cele szczegółowe i dovbat
we właściwym kierunku, aby świat nie zapomniał
konieczne jest tworzenie dysków informacyjnych
aby Ukraina pojawiła się w informacjach
przestronny
pokazują to najnowsze statystyki
w światowych środkach masowego przekazu wzmianki o ukraińskim pro
wojny na Ukrainie pojawiają się 22 razy
rzadziej niż na początku marca
czyli świat zaczyna się nudzić
ten temat i nie chce tak często wojny
słyszymy I dopóki wojna jest z nami, jest nasza
zadanie zrobić je o niej
usłyszał pomocnika
jeśli wiesz co robisz i walczysz
ostatecznie przyniesie to rezultaty
[muzyka]
Zrozumieliśmy, że głównie wszystko od
Europa wkracza teraz do Rosji
mity
ponieważ morze jest zamknięte
niebo jest zamknięte, pozostają tylko ciężarówki
I zdecydowaliśmy
idź dowiedzieć się, co tam jest, czego nie pamiętam
były trzy samochody lub pięciu z nas
w skrócie kilka aut z Warszawy
samochody z Warszawy, zebraliśmy się w autach
tak, że nagle, jeśli jest coś strasznego lub
zaczną nas bić, żebyśmy przynajmniej wiedzieli, kto to jest
z którym przyszedł i było kilku świadków i to
nikt nas tam nie zabił i wyszliśmy
aby zobaczyć, że właśnie zaczęli tam chodzić
zapytaj kierowców, oni nas
powiedział, dlaczego tam stoją
i to wszystko Zrozumieliśmy, co trzeba zablokować
że to znak, że wszystko wywożą do Rosji
z rzędu, że jest prawie tak samo jak było
w kolejce jedzie do Rosji, a nie do żadnej
Białoruś nie leży w Kazachstanie
Podszedłem do policji i powiedziałem, że my
ogłaszamy
spontaniczna, otwarta akcja
zarejestrował go właśnie tam
wysiadł przed ciężarówkę i zatrzymał się i to wszystko
zatrzymała się pierwsza ciężarówka, ciężarówka lub mała
wybór albo idzie do ludzi, albo stoi Ona
stała tylko dlatego, że przed nią stali ludzie
ludzie, oni nie mogli iść do nas, to nie to
bo nie wiem gdzie się zatrzymali i
wszystko dlatego, że staliśmy się pod kołami tylko
dlatego nie poszli. I wtedy się zaczęło
ogromna kolejka, zebrała się cała policja
zebraliśmy się ze strażą graniczną, od której wszyscy zaczynali
targować się z nami, prosić, żebyśmy zeszli I
przepuścić co najmniej 5 samochodów dostawczych na godzinę
jednym słowem służby przystąpiły do ​​wykonywania swoich obowiązków
pracować i zaczęliśmy robić swoje
praca
To nie działa. To tylko ja. Działa
tylko wtedy, gdy wszyscy są razem, gdy ja jestem sam
przybył i stanął na granicy przed ciężarówką
Nie sądzę, żeby coś się zmieniło, naprawdę
a tym bardziej nie wydaje mi się
Unia Europejska przyjęłaby 5 pakietów
klauzulę dotyczącą sankcji, jeśli którakolwiek z nich nie jest jasna
Chuviha stanął przed ciężarówkami.Nie zrobili tego
jesteśmy dzięki ludziom, którzy zrezygnowali ze wszystkiego i
dotarła tam do granicy dzięki ludziom
którzy trafiają na nasze promocje dzięki
ludzie, którzy rysują plakaty, dostają je
trzymajcie dziewczyny, które szyją flagi
dzięki tysiącom ludzi nasza inicjatywa
zauważył W rzeczywistości, jak szybko
czy Ukraina wygra zależy nie tylko od
tych, którzy stoją z przodu i od tych, którzy
dziś z tyłu
i od tych, którzy wspierają nas dzisiaj
teraz bardzo ważne jest, aby mówić o Ukrainie
i każdą okazję do rozmowy o Ukrainie
trzeba go używać, nie my nie możemy
zignoruj ​​​​bocha i Irpin Po prostu wszystko
widziałem teraz takich Erpinów
i Ukrainę, ale nikt ich nie widzi, dlatego
nie wolno nam przestać
zagraniczni dziennikarze, jacy oni fajni
nie znudziły się wcześniej ani później
wojny I nie możemy się nami znudzić
potrzebować
kołysz tą przestrzenią informacyjną i rób tak
był nieustannie bity przez Ukrainę
Jestem nią. Zegar i głód są już kwaterami głównymi
[muzyka]
Dzień dobry dzień dobry
pokazali mi, co się stanie i będzie się działo
dziś w nocy
Samoloty przelatywały obok mojego domu i słyszałem
pierwszy wybuch
i powoli zacząłem się budzić
genialnych ludzi przez telefon lub rozmowy
zmartwychwstał i wypowiedział te uwielbienia
czego nie wiem, nigdy nie powiedziałem
Wszystko Obudź się, nie martw się, zaczęło się
wojna
[muzyka]
Przepraszam przyjaciele, minęły dwa dni
Poszedłem na spacer, wróciłem do telewizji
Teraz będę udawał, że jestem pracowity
Przychodzę na czas всё время Gdyby nie Pashe
Pewnie znowu się spóźniłem
nie zauważyliśmy, że zawsze byłeś na czas
przychodzisz punktualnie
praca
centrali, spójrz na nasze zdjęcia na nich
Piec na drugim zdjęciu to piec Kortsar
przyszedł drugi stopień ochrony
tak, trzeci, i wybieramy go, ciebie
rozumiesz. Spójrz na drugą. Spójrz
сейчас группу штабы Chciałbym podnieść
vopros, gdzie wojskowe biura poborowe dają kamizelkę kuloodporną
żeby tak się nie stało
Wojskowe biuro rekrutacyjne wydało ten sam list: Gdzie jesteśmy?
jesteśmy tu wczoraj
wysłany do centralnego komisariatu i
Do regionalnego biura poborowego wysłano 44 jednostki
Wcześniej zatopiliśmy 50 sztuk
miejskie biuro poborowe przy ulicy Odeskiej
spójrz, dzisiaj powinno przyjść pięć
maszyny na obiecanym er ja na nowym
Widzę, że poczta nadchodzi i chetery obe
przetłumaczyć ludzi tutaj jest fizyczne Cóż
Maszyny do szycia to obiecują
przepis Sasha wyprodukowany przez Gena
odzież i hurtownia Maksym
humanitarna pomoc medyczna
siedziba Ksiuszy, tutejszego szefa sztabu
akkaska Sasha budowa Dima
centrum koordynacyjne i infolinia
Bohdan burzuyki Lera manufaktura
koktajle Mołotowa i transport Kitchen Sonya
Powieść polega na tym, że widzimy, że kłamie, kłamie
tutaj absolutnie nie na długo
sformatowany zostanie zapakowany
minibusy i autobusy oraz samochody i
podróżuje tylko do wojsk danego terytorium
[muzyka]
terytorium dwóch podpodziałów tego samego atomu
medyczny
preparaty medyczne druga p
Tutaj rozpocznie się poniedziałek
przekazaliśmy maszyny szwalni
Podniesiemy dowody domu z ruin i zrobimy to
rozpocząć kolejną zmianę ściegów tutaj
Horlovka Miejsce żołądek dzieci
Mój przyjaciel je wynajmuje
Gena to produkcja huśtawek dla dzieci
zjeżdżalnie, kilka stromych grilli
włożył całą swoją duszę w meble na poddaszu
stworzył najfajniejsze biuro w stylu loftu
человек просто с такой обстоянный po
Z natury Niemiec robi wszystko zgodnie ze swoją naturą
nie robią maksimum, oszaleli, cóż, zrobili
fajne warunki i tak się stało
tutaj jest psychol, to jest shveimy
spawalnia to recepcja
есть Kuchnia, która jest naszą siedzibą
stał się naszym mikrokny iw następstwie na
ten warsztat znajduje się na dużym terytorium
dawnego kompleksu remontowego zajezdni autobusowej i ul
istnieje wiele magazynów pudełek
remonty pomieszczeń magazynowych, biurowych itp
w pewnym momencie stali się właścicielami
w pokoju powiedziano, aby znał klucze
trudno jest robić pewne rzeczy, mój chłopcze
znajomy
szukał swojego kuzyna i
Poradziłem sobie dzięki naszym powiązaniom wojskowym
Wiem, aby znaleźć tego brata, znaleźliśmy go w
kostnica
a dzięki tatuażom dowiedzieli się i tyle
Teraz
przyszedł na rotację, wojownik nie jest na rotację
przyjechał tu w podróży służbowej na pogrzeb
brzydki brat został uwolniony ego my teraz
przed jednym emu w części drugiej kamizelki kuloodpornej
te urządzenia są za granicą, wszystkie są takie same
powiedzieli, po prostu daj pieniądze, jesteś z nami
miejmy na myśli
Powiedziałem W nas, powiedział nam Kak neutho
Trzeba mieć pewność, że rozumiemy, kim jesteśmy
przeznaczamy pieniądze i nas na jego początkujących
wniosek stał się konieczny, wniosek został poinformowany o i
aplikacja jeszcze nie dotarła
czy trzeba było brać i dla komedii?
[muzyka]
dyski
piły do ​​granitu
[muzyka]
ogień
5.45
nie jest to zły wynik, jak to określamy
zdałem trzecią klasę, pewny siebie, chciałem
byłoby 4
W każdym razie pashinukete uważa, że ​​U
jesteśmy tam i przeniesieni do tego momentu, kiedy
szwedzkiej stali nie zabraknie
еще Финская Więc to właśnie zamierzamy zrobić
organizacja przyjęć świątecznych
jakieś zdarzenia parzyste
firma eventowa, która przyniosła tyle radości
zabawa I pracowałem w niej jako kierownik
i prezenterów, którzy to wszystko prowadzili
imprezy kulturalne i masowe itp
okazało się że
duża liczba moich klientów, którzy są
nie trzęsły się, podeszły do ​​mnie i zatrzymały się
uciekłem od termiki, dlaczego miałbym kontynuować ramię
ktoś wysłał pieniądze w kopertach lub
ktoś przyszedł i pomógł na karcie
ręce
Posłuchajmy
pięćset czy coś
[oklaski]
to jest 600D
600 gęstość 40 mm
[muzyka]
120 nas napompuje, co zamówiłem
рекведущего pracuje teraz w warsztacie
Nie wysyłam jej nawet asystentów do szyi
tnie tam wszelkiego rodzaju tkaniny
i przychodzi po to codziennie
Pracuje
w tej chwili kupiliśmy 11 T fajne
stało się, ale rozumiemy, że jest taka potrzeba
około
około 100 ton
nie mamy takich pieniędzy jak tam
kup 100 t i dlatego
skończymy te 11 ton
używać Cóż, tego właśnie użyliśmy
wczesne
w tej chwili produkowanych jest 500 sztuk stali Protek
wykonał 1100 par talerzy i w
większość z nich to ponad ośmiuset nas
stwierdził w tych kamizelkach kuloodpornych, że w
prawdopodobnie poprawne jest powiedzenie łożysko płytowe
które same uszyły naturalnie
produkcja
[muzyka]
a na zebraniu organizacyjnym średnio wszystko
Dobry
[muzyka]
nie będzie pensji
bardzo dobrze stabilnie zrobiliśmy to po raz pierwszy
to dzień wolny bo rozumiemy uh bez
nikt nam kartofli jakoś nie posadzi
Oto notatki tych osób, które tam są
do tego potrzebują kamizelki kuloodpornej
przekażcie ich teraz armii, jakoś ich zdobędziemy
i obiecał, że wyjedzie stąd w piątek i sobotę
pięć banknotów i zaznacz to samo
kamizelki kuloodporne Jestem tu dla esli radovatsya
jeśli nawet się nie śmieją, to wszystko
i to jest bardzo ważne szybko i szybko
i zmiażdżyć głowę z popiołu i
pozwól sobie na radość
[muzyka]
wielcy menedżerowie są wysyłani inaczej
firmy ubezpieczeniowe firmy budowlane
Nie ma tu dyrektorów finansowych
nie ma tu ani jednego urzędnika
kto wystawia rachunki lub wystawia rachunki
rodzaj prac i powstał
fajny Kostyak i tam
12-14 pracowników, którzy byli zamknięci
główne kierunki i zaczął robić wszystko
w tych miejscach jest bardzo szybko
[muzyka]
siebie jako ludzi, którzy działają i robią
genetycznie, a trzeci nawet na wszystko
Jestem strasznie zaniepokojony uczuciami Yury
[muzyka]
przed wojną pracowałem 13 lat w
również w branży IT na różnych stanowiskach
Miałem własny IT przez 7 lat
biznes
Pracowałem głównie przez ostatnie trzy lata
w niemieckich startupach Oczywiście
nastąpiło przewartościowanie wartości, odszedłem
to bardzo fajna praca, bo ja nie
Widzę sens pracy teraz po niemiecku
startup pomimo tego, że projekt w
w zasadzie jest społecznie użyteczna, ale nie jest
porównywalne rzeczy do wojny i życia
Jesteśmy ich współobywatelami, a mój kraj i ja
Wróciłem do Kijowa i ciągle szukałem
Co mógłbym zrobić?
robić i co by się przydało, bo
Oczywiście czułem się jak wielu ludzi
Dima i ja mamy poczucie winy
rozpoczął repertuar od początku
na przykład stworzyłem taki czat na mój dzień
Moje urodziny są 23
W lutym utworzyłem czat i nadałem mu nazwę
Inwazja Cóż, wtedy było jeszcze dużo
Żartowałem, czy będzie inwazja, czy nie
żartował z tego i zapraszał
wielu ludzi dla siebie na cały dzień
narodziny
na imprezę, która miała się odbyć 25 lutego
aw tym czatoku jest Dima i jest też Dasha
wielu moich przyjaciół i odkąd to się stało
prawdziwa inwazja A
impreza jeszcze się nie zaczęła
żyje, a to dopiero początek dnia
narodziny zamieniły się w pogawędkę
wojna iw pewnym momencie przyszedł do mnie Dima
przyszedł i powiedział Może spróbujemy tego jako typ
dodaj tu coś do roboty, chodźmy na wieś
i zobaczmy. Cóż, może nam się uda
Mamy szansę na co najmniej kilka
jakoś pomóc rodzinom, powiedziałem OK
chodźmy
Po prostu zdecydowaliśmy się iść w tym kierunku
Czernihów i zobaczyć, co się dzieje
po wyzwoleniu Czernihowskiej Kijowskiej
i obwód sumski Rozumieliśmy to
Obwód kijowski jest bardzo w centrum uwagi
uwagę, mieliśmy wrażenie, że w
W obwodzie czernihowskim wszystko wygląda dobrze
znacznie gorzej, kiedy tu przybyliśmy
widzieliśmy to co piąty dom
całkowicie zniszczony i całkowicie zniknął
nienaruszone domy Rozumieliśmy to
o własnych siłach mogliśmy
zacznij od naprawy małych budynków
wstaw szybę w oknach i napraw
dach do naprawy wewnętrznej
dekoracyjne i równolegle z tym We
zrozumiał, że to, co zrobić, jest najłatwiejsze
jest zebranie przyjaciół i przyjaciół przyjaciół i
przybyć tu zgodnie ze starożytnym zwyczajem
Myślę, żeby wspólnie posprzątać i posprzątać
jest obecnie bardzo aktualny na Ukrainie
musimy się spotkać. W ten sposób napędza Bo
jeśli nie my To kto to jest dobra rzecz to jest
jest pożyteczny, jest potrzebny ludziom, jest potrzebny nam
Myślę, że sobie pomagamy
znajdujemy się we wsi Yagidne
Gmina Iwanowska obwodu czernihowskiego
ogólnie wieś Yagidne znajdowała się pod
okupacja przez 26 dni wszystkich miejscowych
zgromadził 300 osób w podziemiach szkoły
przebywał tam przez 26 dni
żebyś zrozumiał ten kwadrat, no cóż, prawdopodobnie
130 metrów kwadratowych i 15 osób w dół
zmarł z powodu
nieopisane warunki wentylacyjne
[muzyka]
co jest naszą misją, ponieważ jest nas wielu
rozmawiał z ludźmi z różnych środowisk
brał udział w inicjatywach i został
oczywiste jest, że wolontariat powinien mieć miejsce
coś bardzo trwałego dla ludzi, ponieważ
dużo Niestety wszystko jest spóźnione
i dużo pracy i żebyśmy wszyscy mogli
jest dla nas realistyczne, że w jakiś sposób odbudujemy Ukrainę
potrzebować
dużo pracować, aby tak się stało
konieczne jest, aby stało się to realne, aby dla
interesujący był wolontariat młodzieżowy
rozrywkowy i kulturalny A, ponieważ jest duży
duża część naszego zespołu ds
spotykał się wystarczająco często w przeszłości
uczestniczyliśmy w imprezach niektórych DJ-ów
Wszyscy kochamy muzykę techno
dla klubów stało się jasne, że jeśli my
połączmy 20 kierunków
wtedy może to być coś bardzo ciekawego i bardzo
atrakcyjny i zorganizowaliśmy pierwszy
tylko nasi przyjaciele zostali zaproszeni na spływ
nie było prasy, bo chcieliśmy
poeksperymentować, żeby zobaczyć jak jest u nas
odbędzie się po pierwsze, a po drugie jako
opinia publiczna zareaguje, ponieważ dla nas
wtedy było oczywiste, że w zasadzie istnieje
Mieliśmy też pewien zakaz imprez rozrywkowych
uczucie, że
społeczność może tego nie zaakceptować, ale
nie było skandali
otrzymane
tak wiele entuzjastycznych recenzji od wszystkich
imprezy
jeśli nie wejdziemy, ponieważ są tam przyjaciele
w czasie wojny było mało dobrych wieści, ale w
my Oni są W końcu połączeni
Elektronika
I ogólnie gratuluję wszystkim naszej drugiej
wydajność czyszczenia
i wreszcie możemy zacząć kilka słów
o organizatorach To jest nasza Sasza
nasz reżyser dźwięku iw ogóle
najważniejszą twórczą osobą
Dasha jest odpowiedzialna za dzisiejszy lay-up
Andrzej
Tanya od spraw organizacyjnych I jest jeszcze coś
Odpowiada też za wiek
kwestie organizacyjne Teraz bierzemy
rękawice i weź narzędzie i my wszyscy
Jedziemy tam, aby oczyścić motywy mężczyzn
zdezorientowany swoim ciałem, mówi zdenerwowany
komórki ucha zobaczyły żywy obraz
czerwony płyn rozpalił żyły każdego z nich
Wszyscy chcą tego w radiu
tak że z muzyki Stalin Love Cardio Hardy
hit podczas imprezy sezonowej lub
wypij to konie Słyszysz O ile wiem
centrum kultury w zabudowie
W latach 70. było naprawdę kulturalnie
centrum i taka wspólnota wspólnotowa
organizowanie
Centrum
niezwykle ważne dla lokalnych i
nawet w ostatnich latach jest naprawdę
funkcjonował
dom składa się z kilku pokoi
a także znajdująca się tam hala sportowa
trochę tam z boku
to jest powieść
kto jest szefem tego centrum kultury
wieś spalona od najeźdźców rosyjskich
na małych uliczkach zawsze są dzieci
są ludzie, którzy tu chodzili
ten klub na koncerty
ale przede wszystkim jestem wdzięczny wolontariuszom
którzy pomagają nam teraz w tym trudnym czasie
swoją życzliwością i pracą
pokazać, że jesteśmy silni i nie odejdziemy
siebie w tarapatach
w czasie okupacji mieszkaliśmy z rodziną
w miejscu zamieszkania weszliśmy do tego
okupanci siłą zajęli naszą piwnicę
dziecko miało wtedy sześć lat
miesiące
przeżywanie tego wszystkiego było bardzo trudne
zobaczyłem, jak wszystko wokół płonęło, zobaczyłem jak
wieś i
żył jeden dzień w tym czasie, ale przyszedł
czas i może mieliśmy szczęście, że się wydostaliśmy
było więcej żyjących z tego piekła
jest to przerażające dla małej, ponieważ nie jest na to gotowa
zasługuje
mam nadzieję
dziecko nie będzie pamiętało tego horroru
tego strachu i
będzie żył szczęśliwie w Szczęśliwej Ukrainie
świata rasy kozackiej, nie ma tłumaczenia
i to samo na Ukrainie, Ukraina wygra
ona jest silna ona jest bardzo silna to jest nasze
nie było z nami naszego ukochanego traktorzysty
we wszystkich przypadkach jest to już ósmy raz
lokalni, ale pracują za darmo
dziś przybyło do nas około 200
wolontariuszy I przywieźliśmy trzy autobusy i
Myślę też o 10-15 autach
na naszą imprezę przybyło około 25 osób
są także cudzoziemcami, począwszy od drugiego
w wydarzeniu biorą udział ludzie z
zupełnie inne kraje, generalnie zachodnie
krajów, czyli Kanady, dzisiejszych Stanów Zjednoczonych
Niemcy Polska
i mamy takich międzynarodowych wolontariuszy, którzy
zawsze jeżdżą tym z nami
Marynata Oksana
mówią, że widzieli komórki nerwowe uszu
jasny obraz został zapalony przez czerwony płyn
życie każdego człowieka jest przede wszystkim naszym
Kamunicha jednoczy ludzi, którzy mają
wspólna wizja tego, co się teraz dzieje
takich wydarzeń historycznych nie można
siedzenie w domu i patrzenie w telefon
Trzeba się w jakiś sposób przyczynić
jeśli nie jesteś z przodu
a jak masz pracę to ok
to normalne, ale są weekendy i ty jesteś w weekendy
możesz iść, a także pomóc i
przede wszystkim czerpać z tego przyjemność
chodzi o społeczność ludzi, którzy
czuć to samo, co my czujemy
po drugie, chodzi o ludzi, którzy
poczuj, że wartości są teraz
są wybrani
Ukraina jako społeczeństwo
wartości wolności, demokracji, praw człowieka
to wszystko
Czujemy dla siebie najważniejsze rzeczy
jest bardzo ostry i wierzymy, że go mamy
już teraz
to od nas zależy zmiana społeczeństwa
wywierać wpływ, musimy dawać im przykład
samochód jest taki, że pracuję z przyjaciółmi i z
podobnie myślący ja
energetyzuje
będzie barszcz, chudy barszcz wegański
ukraiński ukraiński
ABC
[muzyka]
przypomina mi
czasy kiedy nie było wojny Kiedy wszystko było
ok, kiedy
ludzie byli otwarci tak jak teraz i
wiedzieliśmy, jak odpocząć
Jestem bardzo zaniepokojony faktem, że w niektórych
chwila nie zamieniła się w
smutny naród, naprawdę nie chcę tego od nas wszystkich
doświadczają stresu pourazowego
A to dużo
będzie bardziej użyteczny dla Ukrainy
nieco zdrowsi ludzie, którzy będą
do nieustannej pracy na rzecz odbudowy Ukrainy
niż ludzie w depresji, którzy będą siedzieć
sobie w domu
[muzyka]
na początku Jechaliśmy
to była orifleira
jednodniowe wycieczki
A ja jakoś chciałem więcej, no cóż, więcej
coś do zrobienia Jesteśmy tam z innymi
wolontariusze przyjrzeli się, co w zasadzie
taka pomoc jest potrzebna
jest również potrzebny w obwodzie kijowskim
jest wiele miejsc, w których potrzebujesz fizycznego
pomoc jest taka
stało się pytaniem
jak się tam dostać
mój wujek miał ten bouse bezczynny
Cóż, w zasadzie mówię mojemu wujkowi, co może
Bory wziąłem i
dosłownie gdzieś w tym czasie
już się zaczęły
naprawy, czyli osoba zajmująca się naprawami już je ma
pomogli niektórym rodzinom
remont
wtedy konieczne było pozycjonowanie materiałów budowlanych
Pomogłem w tym, a potem jakoś
poszedł poszedł poszedł poszedł
ona już jest czymś
My
Spóźniłem się tak dobrze, chodźmy na pierogi
Tam wszyscy na ciebie czekają
ogórki ogórki
to są dziewczynki i dzieci pisane wielką literą
ale przybyli do naszej wioski
i pomóż nam wszystkim na świecie całemu mnie
Zrozumiałem w sercu, że to było moje
został Wareniczką
nawet senną truskawkę
Tamta jagoda nie jest twoja, jest cała moja
I nic więcej nie potrzebuję
podpowie co ugotować lub czy są dobre
takiej osobie nie rosną skrzydła i wszystko na świecie
torba all I'm ready wisi do prania
A kiedy ostatnio spędziłeś tu godzinę?
To były urodziny w Słyszysz trochę Tak
jesteśmy w tym
na jeziorze na wodzie słychać I jesteśmy tacy dobrzy
wszyscy na świecie tak siedzieli i pływali
Tak, my też pływamy
22 godziny
Godzina 10 i ważę wnuczkę w swojej i tyle
altana, której jest nasza
[muzyka]
Jak nastrój pierogów
Mówię tak, chcę więcej, idę, patrz
[muzyka]
[oklaski]
o jakim życzeniu wspomniałeś
Najważniejszy jest pokój, pokój to pokój
nie płacz w dniu dzisiejszych urodzin
Dzisiaj
jeszcze raz Życzymy Ci tego
płakała odtąd już tylko z radości A
teraz chodźmy świętować
[oklaski]
zmienia się mentalność naszych ludzi
naprawdę możemy
zjednoczyć się wokół wartości klasowych
i widzę efekt mojej pracy
[muzyka]
Naprawdę mam nadzieję, że to się zmieni
cały ruch ludzi, którzy będą
stale angażować się w odbudowę Ukrainy
bo jesteśmy silnym narodem
[muzyka]
[oklaski]